(Evelyn belches loudly)
- [Evelyn] Mm.
Okay.
- [Interviewer] Good morning, Evelyn.
- Fine, I found a white shirt.
I wanted to have an embroidery
on Christmas Day, 1972.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yup.
They turned it into a
backyard garden, yup.
Uh...
Mm, I have to ask Thelma
that, Thelma Judy.
She used to walk up and down
the streets scrubbing toilets.
She was age 69 when she was born.
She's from Atlanta.
It wasn't named Georgia
then, til I was born.
I was a Georgia peach when I was about,
uh, nine years old.
Do you mind if I light up?
- [Interviewer] No, go ahead.
(lighter clicks)
Where did you grow up, Evelyn?
- Kennewick, Washington.
I moved to Benton County when
I got a birth certificate.
I was three years old.
From three to seven, that was all I had.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your mom and dad.
- Well, my mom was a
handicap rights servant,
that's what she called it.
And she wrote down the word right,
and I went to college that
day to the local library,
and started studying science.
Why sugar was needed, made, and
in clothes.
And I found this braided bread,
and I ate all of it.
It was a sugared donut.
I brought it home, and
two more of them appeared.
(sucks cigarette loudly)
I had a kitchen counter with
little gold stars on it.
But we got a teapot for Christmas in 1978.
That thing was very dangerous.
My dad took it down to the desert,
and Jean, our neighbor,
shot it with a rifle.
Those were the first
(indistinct) in our neighborhood.
- [Interviewer] Yeah?
- Yeah, our legs were very ungainly.
That was the only bread
for about four months,
were those three braided sugar rolls.
Somehow cinnamon got into my...
Guess coffee's been here since 1801.
(sucks cigarette loudly)
Those coffee lids with
the separation in it
means a sign of peace.
But it has, bubble gum is part of it.
That comes from petroleum.
And (indistinct).
It holds the top of the fruit in
so you can see inside parts of the body.
I don't think you can
see inside everything.
Everything is everything. (chuckles)
I was told that in New York the next day.
Somebody handed me a glass of champagne,
and I saw a prima ballerina,
and they were so thin.
But their legs were
nice, and they all waved.
There was about six,
seven, or eight of 'em,
and I found a quarter behind
one of their pink slippers,
and I saw the heels of it,
they have wood in their toes.
Very painful.
(sucks cigarette loudly)
Anyway, I got up, and they all gasped,
and I found raspberry yogurt.
They didn't have a label,
but as I rubbed the quarter against it
to keep my fingers from being frozen,
I thought there was a lotta land,
and that it was always Christmas or coal.
That was my third night in New York City.
I went there to become a writer
'cause I knew that the east
coast has very little food
and a lotta people.
(lips smacking)
Also, more New Yorkers get
married than anyone else.
Chicago rates highest in
divorce, separated families.
(loud sucking)
Welfare was started in 1936,
the same year as the Dewey Decimal System.
The libraries came about,
come about every three years.
(singing) I'll be around
about (sucks loudly).
(sucks loudly) Pinocchio.
Yeah, that man who
assaulted me this morning,
I went to a movie with 'em,
and he ordered a caramel bar.
(coughs) And ate it in
front of the exit doors.
And the thing about
being touched on the nose
by a light bulb.
That is what you'd see if
you pigged out on chocolate
in front of a theater as a kid.
My jacket's going out of style.
I've lost a lotta wool.
Those paper bags are related to red hair.
To mine, anyway, 'cause I
used to fill up sacks of candy
for my friends on holidays.
We had three, or just
two Halloween's together.
We'd eat gumball after
gumball, sweet tarts.
We never heard of teeth, or sugar,
or bomb, or anything like that.
And they had rotten teeth
by the time we were seven years old.
(sucks loudly)
But I went to private
school for three years
before I learned about teeth.
We'd run and kick balls, and
the teachers would watch us.
They we're a reflection
off of bowling pins.
There was a bowling alley
that we retreated to in the evening.
(sucks loudly)
It had 21 lanes of bowling.
(smacking lips) That's before numbers
one, two, three, four, 51.
(clearing throat and smacking lips)
I had a big humps.
That was all I ate for
lunch for about four years.
Those nuts were soft,
and that's when people were really scared.
I know the feeling.
(sucks loudly)
But you can't carry it with ya.
I was voted Democratic
Recycling Committee Chairperson,
and it was... Bush was elected
president the next day.
That was my first day of
black and white television.
I thought the world had died.
'Cause I started watching television
when I was two days old.
I saw "Bewitched" with Samantha Stephens.
Somehow I got into kindergarten
and painted a flag.
My arms were real short,
and they were puffed up.
So they took me to a hospital,
and laid me under cool sheets,
and gave me strawberry sherbert,
a little glass of root beer,
and I kept that glass for
18 years. (light chuckle)
It made my kitchen counter.
When I took it down, I was 16 then.
I'd just gotten home from Hawaii.
I was being hooked out then.
When one didn't come to
class, we ran down the street,
and I met a woman named Mrs. Lipburg,
and she fed me for the day.
And the next day a woman
flew in from Wisconsin.
She was hoping to be a
nurse, that's what I thought.
(belches loudly)
And she became my mother.
It's hard to record details of life
when you're, uh...
(clears throat)
just home from the hospital.
One man had a bump on
his head an inch high.
But I did get some sleep,
and get to wash my feet, my body,
got to read Mark Twain,
how to paint a fence.
Did some push-ups and jumping jacks.
Watched television for 18 hours.
That's six days.
Saw (indistinct) bottles of wine.
And nice to see the dress with black lace.
Saw my mom's living room.
Yeah, yeah, when I found
out that I had a mom,
I smiled to myself, and I
always have kept my secret.
(tongue smacks loudly)
Most people don't know what a secret is.
That would be a personal play item.
But I had cancer, I was on life support.
I only had legs with... I walked up
with the (indistinct) street.
I wasn't interested in
the front of my body.
That was my second
afternoon in San Francisco.
It was really hot.
The sun was blazing, and going everywhere.
People were eating bagels,
coffee spilling, recycling.
I did that at peach coffee
when they reminded me of raisin bagel.
I finally found a jar of sour cream,
and a man split his bagel with me,
then he asked for a bath,
but I didn't give it
to 'em, I felt so bad.
I thought I'd starve him to death.
But I found 'em outside the door,
and we took a taxi ride
up to the Cadillac market.
It just had one door in it,
but it did have a cash
machine made from taxi stores.
That silver made by water, soft drinks,
white socks, pink vagina,
apples, peaches, pumpkin pie.
Then I went to McDonald's.
- [Interviewer] Are you a good cook?
- I like grease. I can take
hot temperatures in cooking.
But cool soda is my favorite.
But it's hard to be away from the world.
That's what drinking does, takes you away.
(tongue smacking)
Yeah, I was in Bond,
my 50 in San Francisco.
It turned to evening really rapidly.
And the bus stop went in
where people were almost dead.
You know, they'd been on
there for about 55 hours
without a juice or anything.
So I brought a cranberry juice
and a stack of styrofoam cups,
and that day I found out
that sealed containers
make you hard of hearing.
Later that same year,
I was behind cardboard men stacked up
who we thought was a homeless.
He nearly murdered me.
I nearly lost, uh,
my right breast,
which is milk and creamery diet.
I had a jar of cool cream.
Then I drank the whole thing,
and I started training for
the Olympics that afternoon.
I was 12 years old.
I finally got flesh on my
face before in my bones.
I was in the movie elephant years.
When I was 18, I was
sad that I was so ugly
that I scared people.
At 12, that's your formative years.
That's about the time you start worrying
about the world events comes next.
I saw NBC programming,
and I watched "60 Minutes" that night,
and I saw drug dealin',
how people would bust into
your house in uniform,
and just stand there.
And fat people, those are
the saddest people on earth.
That means someone in their
life is crying, or they are.
But water is part of tears,
so you should drink it
so that you can have
a grape, or something like that.
That sustained me for four hours
that I waited in front of
the office for a check,
or a glass of soup.
(singing "Lady Marmalade" in gibberish)
(clears throat)
That's about hooking in New Orleans.
I was 15 years old then
on my way to become a Navy Seal.
But I got reigned out of the bus,
and the uniformed men came in,
and let me board to Montana,
and I worked there for seven
months to pay for a backpack
and a bowling bag to take into the Army.
Since he was uniformed, I
thought that was handsome.
I like the color green,
and gold, and black.
It was lace. It was dignified.
It was the first uniform I saw,
then I came home that night,
and my dad had on a tan robe.
I thought, "Wow, you really
do have to share clothes."
I thought, "What was that other thought?"
And I like to think it was
love was a giving thing
as my dad tied the robe
around his thin waist.
He was just getting it together then,
but he lost it the next morning, even.
I was so young, I had never
heard of food or eggs,
or cracking open, or hard work.
So he bought me a bike for 17 cents.
He made it from his bottle caps.
People thought they were
many slight of hand.
I learned magic that day.
My friend, she was my gymnast partner.
She used to watch me, we'd
do stretches together,
and I looked at her
legs, and up her pussy,
and I saw gold there.
And that was my first
range of sports equipment.
Yeah, that was all the
clothes we had, was shorts.
Some would come in with
just a white tee shirt on.
We thought that was cool
until the showers started running,
and people were streaked with water,
then no oil afterwards.
I remember that day now. My skin so dry.
I ran down the road ready
to just kill someone.
And I said someone, is that a...
And there was a deli there,
or a fine restaurant.
That would be if you're starving,
and home from high school.
I called restaurants a school, too
'cause you will learn
what people look like,
what they can do.
(clears throat) And by eating with 'em.
That can take seven hours.
- [Interviewer] What's your favorite food?
- Uh, broccoli noodles
with spice beef.
I had a garlic farm.
It was 12 acres.
That next night I went to the beach,
and it turned morning in four hours.
I had to walk through grass,
I met two girls there.
One was behind me, one was in front of me.
I put it on my back.
I didn't know the word lifting weights,
but I learned that day.
She had a little sports backyard.
We built a hot tub with boy's legs.
We were nearly murdered for doing that
as we boarded a ferry.
They came at us with an ax,
and darts, and everything.
That's what that redwood made.
We stayed outta hot tubs.
And as I was so exhausted,
and so on my own,
I hadn't made it out there
with just 17 people in the world.
I went around poking the taxi window
on my way to a hot tub.
A man had invited me.
He drank water, and he
wouldn't give me any,
so I put my hand on his
knee and squeezed it,
and then he became the happy camper.
I think that's probably when
you came into existence.
He's healthy, he's your friend.
I laid on that table,
and he put a warm towel on my back,
and I slept for 17 hours.
Everybody's ready to take on the world.
I walked downtown, saw the opera center.
Very long, very...
I thought the world was
not in very good shape.
I walked without water,
so I went on a 12 mile
hike up to General Hospital
seeking hills 'cause I know
that water runs downhill.
And all I had was a roast
beef sandwich, very thirsty.
So I asked for a token.
And the world was still so
low that they gave it to me.
I found a McDonald's, and ordered a Coke.
Never heard of money being
paid for by a dying person.
And she gave me the Coke, and
she came over to the table,
and her hips made a man named Gene Kelly.
Now McDonald's is responsible
for putting in videos
for delayed syndrome.
You take the bus, I'll go shopping.
The kid's born. Delayed syndrome.
We better meet up somehow.
Stand outside the door, and
show me your leg or your coat.
Camel haired coat, tan clothing
will make you hit and run
if you're a brunette girl.
Brunette is usually the love
of spicy food and late nights.
Probably one room though only, dark hair.
When cardboard first appeared,
that's the first day that I
gave up my birth certificate.
I had done 15 jumping jacks.
Knowing that you had to entertain yourself
when the world is long.
And it was. There were
no maps and bus stops.
Just that one down in Bond,
but that was taken by rain and smoke.
(clears throat)
- [Interviewer] Evelyn, what's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- Uh,
not to mix marriage and pleasure.
(smacks lips)
If you wanna marry someone, just say,
"Would you like an orange?"
And if they don't want the orange,
then they're not right for you
because your mind needs the right one.
That was my leaving of home.
I thought those thoughts, and
wrote it down on a postcard,
and my dad kept that letter.
When I came home from the Army,
I still wanted to be a Navy Seal.
I went down the road, and
there was a gigantic pool,
and I dived in, and had
a terrific afternoon.
As I climbed out, two women were born.
One was 13, and one was two years old,
and she's still very fragile.
(clears throat)
I went to L.A. the next
day so cool from the pool.
It was just 34 miles away from the pool.
But that was before clocks,
so I thought it was
three-and-a-half miles.
I walked into a front yard,
and the door slammed and
closed, and slammed and closed.
And I didn't know the
word hurt, or kidnapping,
or murder, or anything like that.
I thought I was still gonna
be refreshed or saved.
And if I wanted to touch
the door and go into a home
and meet people and
tell 'em about the pool,
and what a fine day I had.
I touched a lot, and a woman
looked out a square window,
and she scared me to death.
I ran all the way home,
and cried against the neighbor's window.
And I played as a seven year old
putting my fingers on my head,
and pretending I was a horse.
Ran around in the grass until it burned.
Went nextdoor,
almost ready to kill for shoes.
That's how angry children can
be when they're neglected.
(lips smacking)
But, somebody'll right 'em.
They may get a broken cheekbone
from somebody's who's homeless.
Most people don't have any fastenings.
(lips smacking)
I became President of the
Democratic Chairman Committee
when I found my...
When I found a public school library.
That was the first word I saw: P-R-E-S.
In written form.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think of our president?
- Uh, I like Clinton. He's
from the south. He eats good.
And his college partner,
Hillary, is not his wife.
That's his college partner.
Bill Clinton, and Hillary.
He's kind of a professor guy,
but he's more of a farmer,
and a lazy fat ass.
He's a redneck. So is Jimmy Carter.
Some (indistinct).
Knives, spoons. Spoons
not very entertaining men.
Forks, you'll make a clock.
You can eat beans, and lots of foods.
Beans heat up in fields,
or grow under sand, and
can find their way out.
If you keep walking.
If you go barefoot,
let your feet get salt
on 'em from the earth
the way people move.
Most people are in tears, but
panic attacks are the worst.
Or assault to the face, back,
neck, or leg, ankle, toe.
So, I took ballet lessons for seven hours.
I paid 15 cents that my dad
had given (clears throat) me
from model in my bikini.
That was my only friend for 13 years,
was that yellow polka-dot bikini.
It had pink flowers.
One was down here, one... my
breasts are uneven. One's big.
But they're still nice
if boys like sweet icing.
I won a cake walk when
I was seven years old.
I was taken to school
to see why the teacher would come back.
That was all the thought we had.
I thought, "That's very good."
And I found sports equipment,
and played in my backyard.
Badminton with nets. Bought
me the Saudi Arabia tent.
So I took it on.
I rode my bike through the desert.
Bikes were free back then.
We'd trade 'em. We'd find
'em all over the place.
They changed from orange,
to purple, to red.
They were real pretty.
You just see the end
of red in the evening.
I remember that night.
Black has been here, that's part of tar.
The earth melting and moving.
I walked across a...
A volcano.
Easter has existed since 1 B.C.
That's the edge of the ocean.
You can find shells down there.
That's what you have to give
to someone for a holiday,
or to praise them.
I started saying now it's
like hauling cardboard.
It was layered up.
I thought it was interesting
'cause I've always known
that song James Brown.
Well, I have since New Orleans.
I was, uh,
kept from going on the bus
because it had no seats.
They were being used in schools.
Yeah, but we were chased by axes
for putting up that hot
tub with boy's legs.
But they were just lying
all over the floor.
So I learned creation theory in the force.
I just had two inches
of water, I... (belches)
My brother wanted to go to college.
He left that afternoon
for Arizona in his truck.
For some reason he likes gasoline.
- [Interviewer] Evelyn,
do you believe in God?
- Yeah, I do. Not all the time.
I get too worn out. He probably does too.
It can be just a piece of
food that you're missing.
But you'll feel better
if you stay away from
words like flower power,
stuff like that.
That'll make you walk into someone
because everybody likes a nice person.
But that'll make you a
real (indistinct) too.
I've learned that people are not loyal.
They get sunburn.
Forrest Gump, he's, even
though he's a black man,
he's a redneck.
And he likes girls. He'll
give them their props.
Props, hair brushes, candy bars.
Let 'em look at his black
socks, his mismatched shoes.
(Evelyn singing)
♪ Dream weaver ♪
♪ I believe we can touch the morning sky ♪
♪ There'll always be an answer ♪
Then I was in Seattle selling...
I was in two places at one
time when I was a cashier.
I saw the cash drawer, and
it didn't interest me at all
because I had so few clothes.
Something that was important
was when my sister appeared.
I'd seen her marriage.
She and her husband are still in love.
They own a farm, and she
milks cows and raises goats.
That's her private life.
'Cause I reached out.
I was visiting her to say
goodbye to (indistinct).
And she said, "Evelyn, don't you dare."
I speak differently than her
because I'm three years younger
than her in college years.
But she was born 83 months
before me on Christmas Eve, 1956.
My mother was so happy.
I remember her face. I was two years old.
How that happened, I do not know.
Probably fell out my mother's
arms, (indistinct) taking.
She's from Montana.
- [Interviewer] Evelyn, would
you like me to take you back?
I don't wanna wear you out.
- Yeah, sure.
- [Interviewer] I don't
want you to get too tired.
- [Evelyn] Sure.
- [Interviewer] Maybe we'll
do this again tomorrow.
- [Evelyn] Okay.
- [Interviewer] Cool.
Thank you, darlin', that was wonderful.
- [Evelyn] Sure.
- [Interviewer] It's always
fun listening to you.
- [Evelyn] Thank you.